vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Daniela Blandón Daniela saludo para
usted la secretaria del tesoro Janet
jaellen hablará hoy ante la asociación
de banqueros estadounidenses sí Ángela y
ya se han conocido extractos de su
discurso por ejemplo podría decir que es
que es posible que se justifiquen más
medidas para proteger a los depositantes
bancarios sin instituciones más pequeñas
sufren corridas que amenacen con un
mayor contagio esto ha sido muy polémico
desde el inicio porque en el caso de
silicon Valley Bank el gobierno salió a
tranquilizar al público diciéndole que
el 100% de sus depósitos estaba
garantizado por la corporación Federal
de seguros de depósitos Pues en la
controversia tiene que ver con que esa
garantía se activa solamente para sumas
menores a 250 mil dólares Así que en el
ambiente quedó la idea de que
devolverles todos los depósitos a los
clientes era una especie de rescate
ahora la agencia especializada bloomberg
señala que la Casa Blanca está buscando
la manera de expandirte temporalmente
esa cobertura como una medida de
emergencia hasta que pase toda esta
turbulencia pero sin el consentimiento
del Congreso justamente que han dicho en
el congreso pues Ángel al grupo de 37
republicanos de línea dura en la cámara
de representantes conocido como House
freedom caucos prometió oponerse a esa
garantía universal más alta del límite
actual Pues dice que esta medida
marcaría un peligroso precedente que
alienta a futuros comportamientos
irresponsables que después deben pagar
Quienes no están involucrados y Si
siguen las reglas del mercado
hay amenazas entre tanto Daniela de que
la operación de compra del Credit swiss
pase al plano legal se complica el tema
se complica el tema porque mire esta
compra del banco más grande de Suiza
hacia su rival inmediato que es Credit
Suiza el segundo ha sido controversial
por un lado hubo 17 mil millones de
dólares en bonos conocidos Como at1 que
fueron reducidos a cero con esta
operación normalmente cuando hay una
quiebra bancaria los tenedores de bonos
están por encima de los accionistas en
la repartición de lo que quede Pero no
en este caso por el tipo de Bono también
por La regulación Suiza por otro lado
también hay accionistas institucionales
en especial los fondos de pensiones que
evalúan interponer acciones legales
porque consideran que lluvias ostentará
una peligrosa posición dominante y
porque dicen que creditch será vendido a
un precio de 60% menor al que valía la
bolsa cuando se anunció esta transacción
Y es que a todas luces Dicen que
analistas dicen que el gran beneficiado
es y no precisamente creditch como vamos
a escuchar a continuación
creo que los clientes y los inversores
están más o menos protegidos ahora se ha
eliminado el miedo al contagio Pero por
supuesto para los accionistas de
creditch es difícil perderán mucho
[Música]
es muy buen banco tiene mucha gente
buena y muy buenas líneas de negocio Así
que tres mil millones de dólares Es
realmente barato y el gobierno está
dando todo tipo de garantías líneas de
liquidez adicionales incluso 9 mil
millones de francos suizos si hay algún
problema con pérdidas inesperadas
Entonces es un muy muy buen negocio para
GPS
pasemos a los indicadores pues Estados
Unidos abrió al alza después de una muy
buena jornada el lunes y es que después
de dos semanas tumultosas que culminaron
con esta adquisición de Credit suiz por
parte de su rival y vs la atención ahora
se ha desplazado desde luego a la
reunión de la reserva Federal que
comienza hoy y que termina mañana con
esa esperada decisión de qué van a hacer
con las tasas de interés en Estados
Unidos las acciones en Europa también se
mueven en terreno positivo con el
mercado relativamente tranquilo después
de que los bancos centrales de Estados
Unidos Europa y Japón anunciaran el
domingo en la noche medidas para aliviar
las tensiones en el sistema financiero
por ejemplo
incluyen el préstamo de más dólares y
fuera necesario en caso de que el
mercado pues lo así lo requiera bueno y
vamos ahora a su cifra del día son
16.680 millones de libras esterlinas
esto es un poco más de 20 mil millones
de dólares fue el déficit presupuestario
de Gran Bretaña en febrero de 2023 de
acuerdo con la oficina de estadísticas
Este es el mayor déficit registrado para
un mes de febrero desde que iniciaron
las lecturas en 1993 y lo que aumentó
este faltante en la caja de la nación
fue principalmente el alivio a las
facturas energéticas que precisamente
acaba de ser extendido al menos hasta la
mitad de este año sigue siendo tema el
Reino Unido gracias a usted Daniela
Bueno nos vemos mañana